[Music]
so i
am calling to see how to reconnect with
my husband after i broke up with my
boyfriend this will be good go ahead had
marriage problems and we thought the way
to fix it was to go to polyamory oh
sweet that obviously ended in a great
big ball of burning fire
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney's show and i've been around
the world and iii
i can't find my baby
hey listen we have some people in the
lobby
and she straight up rolled up here in a
dog mom's shirt
just saying way to go i'm that was
clutch that was awesome and you're
wearing a fishing shirt dude and that's
pretty cool too
so we have one rational person at that
at the couches
well done all right that made me happy
hey uh hope everybody had a good weekend
hey um
kelly everybody we
got back from the first i know this is
out of order here so
the show is coming out a month after
these things are actually happening but
we got back from book tour dude and it
was
a bananas and we went to phoenix and
then we'll be heading to texas this week
but dude in phoenix the number of people
who came up and hung out with us and
man listening to this show made me so
happy it made me so happy uh we often
just hang out in here by ourselves and
we just all go home and the fact that
y'all are listening to this is just fun
watching on on the tubes is really cool
so thank you so much we'll see you in
texas this week but by the time this
comes out we'll already have been there
and hopefully we all made it we all
lived to tell the story otherwise this
would be a cool like
i don't know backstage podcast how that
works all right let's go to ophelia in
asheville north carolina what's up
ophelia
hi how are we
doing oh you know hanging in there
oh you know
oh man
so what's going on
um so i
am calling to see how to reconnect with
my husband after i broke up with my
boyfriend
this will be good go ahead fill me in
yeah so
i don't know blame covid or deployments
or that my ace score of six i don't know
we
had marriage problems and we thought the
way to fix it was to go to polyamory
with other people who
were more emotionally connected and
that obviously ended in a great big ball
of burning fire yeah tell me about so
first tell me about how y'all came to
that conclusion who came to who
so i came to him i was presented with
the offer from a mutual friend of ours
and
because i was talking to him about our
problems and he was like i'll sleep with
you
basically yeah i'll sleep with you i'll
be your emotional connection i
you know that will be great for all of
us i'll take one for the team
exactly
hey what a great guy um fantastic
there's a lot of people in the world
that would have just
not done that and but man
wow and so you sit down with your
husband and you're like so i've got an
offer for you how'd that go
um at first he's like i don't understand
why and then he was like well i can have
someone as well so we might as well just
try it and then
it was about six months of like lust
puppy love happiness of yeah i can
have attention when my husband's not
giving me any and then
it ended up being that the person
treating me like terribly and then i
broke it off and now we're trying to
just kind of stand here in the ashes
like well now what do we do did your
husband date anybody
yeah he did
and uh how does that sit with you
at the time i didn't care i was just
happy that we could all be doing this
like amicable adults like quotation
marks around that and then
now i don't like it as much now that i'm
realizing i still want to be with my
husband and
want to fix all the things that are
broken in our relationship
so what is broken in your relationship
um it's
more of the lack of emotional connection
we got married at 18 and didn't know who
we were or what was happening and i had
a bunch of childhood trauma that i've
been in therapy now for two years
finally working through and now that i'm
getting healthier i want to actually
turn around and like fix the issues in
my relationship rather just being in
survival mode
and how's your husband doing
um
you know he's just there he's
he started therapy finally he's more
than just there ophelia
like how's he doing
because he watched here's the thing he
watched his wife come and say listen
you're not meeting this need for me
i think i found like this really giving
kind guy said he would be happy to step
in
and have none of the emotional support
and all of the sexual intimacy support
again great guy world class
and
um
and then he watched you go off and and
basically fall in love with somebody
yeah and yeah he hung around at home
how's he doing now
um he hasn't actually talked about it
really i mean he said that he was okay
with it when it was happening and i was
very honest about all of these feelings
and emotions and anytime he wanted
details about like
weekends we spent together something i
would tell him and
he hasn't said anything i can't honestly
say i've asked though
yeah yeah i was asking my question does
he have permission to speak into that or
two
i'm just trying to roll through that in
my mind and
like sitting down with my wife and
having that conversation and i imagine
everything would be so compressed i
would i think my body would take over at
that point and just numb me out you know
what i mean
like that'd be the only way to get
through the day
um
so here's my
belief
is that
give me give me let me before i give you
my beliefs um give me a
describe to me what you felt with this
new person in month one
um
like i was happy that i
was getting attention and that somebody
was underneath that
like um
i mean there was shame honestly
underneath it underneath that i'm not
looking for negative things i'm um okay
like what did you feel
i mean i didn't eat for two weeks if
that's what you're asking
no
the most common
word that we hear in this in this world
when somebody cheats on somebody when
somebody um even has like agreed
non-monogamy for a season
the word most common heard is the word
alive
i felt alive again
yeah and
it feels so it's just like cocaine it's
fireworks it's cotton candy it's the
greatest feeling after feeling
quote-unquote not alive for so long
i don't think this had anything to do
with this other guy
at all
i think it had everything to do with you
and for some reason in the relationship
you are currently in your marriage
you've chosen
death
and then for some reason you chose
life
with somebody who's abusive and took
advantage of you
and um
i'm not saying all people take advantage
of all people but this guy clearly saw
an opportunity and
um
am i right he didn't treat you well
right
right yeah i mean at first it felt like
it and then no yeah so
um but that even even your willingness
to take that sort of this some of this
is really great and some of this is
terrible but
it all felt alive
right
and so my question to you is why are you
choosing
to not be alive in your marriage
because life's so short man we get one
shot
i think we just got complacent
we
i mean we've
known each other basically our entire
lives and we stopped trying
and i didn't think that we could go back
to trying so
this other avenue looked really good
and so now you're back to wanting to try
again tell me what you've tried how
when's the last time you slept with
somebody else
over a year ago okay so
um
y'all called it off right you said no
that was a terrible idea
yeah and then we tried to stay friends
for a bit and that obviously didn't work
either so then it's been about four
months since
all communication stopped okay so now
you and your husband have y'all called
this off
yes okay and so now you're staring at
each other being like so
what now
yeah what have you tried
um we went to a marriage retreat
together and didn't really get anything
out of that
um
we have a vacation planned to iceland
later like in the fall time
um
that's yeah that's pretty much it
so you just gave me two more
firework shows
and you need to hear me say that's not
how desire is built
okay those are fun i mean
i mean don't get me wrong those are fun
and a blast and it's cool to shake the
snow globe up and it's cool to change
environments that's all great
this is a daily choice that i want to be
alive
i want to be alive in my skin
this is a daily choice that me and this
guy are going to sit across the table
and say
we got one shot at this we did something
stupid it didn't help us at all and now
we're living in the ash of this so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start this thing over which is awesome
and we're going to build something
totally new
and the cool thing about it is you get
to build something totally new but you
got to stop with the well i guess we
just quit trying and we've known each
other for life all that crap none of it
matters i could care less about any of
it everything
is about what are we going to do
tomorrow
and what are we going to do today you
know what i mean because you you come
bearing all these excuses
and honestly i don't care about your
aces score i do because i love you and
you know i love talking about trauma and
stuff we can have that conversation
all these things you're working through
which is fantastic
at some point you have to decide i'm
worth living
alive in my own skin which means i'm
gonna work i'm worth living alive in my
relationships
which means
i'm worth when things are a little
running a little bit low that's okay
because it's cold outside
and i'm going to have some communication
and some practices with my husband that
we know how to turn the heat back up
when it's time
and until you can make and that's hard
that's what i like that's adult stuff
it's tough man it's boring it's day
after day after day and holy crap it's
worth it it's worth every step of the
way
if he'll play along will he play
yeah he will he
that he's so
into keeping the relationship going i
think that was part of it too is that he
wanted to keep me happy and so he agreed
to it so you're gonna have to process
that shame and say that out loud have
you told him that because here's the
thing now you're gonna start beating
yourself up over it
yeah
right
yep
completely and he doesn't need
yet another
you don't need this you know what i mean
yeah so can you forgive you
can you forgive y'all and put a period
at the end of it and then go excavate
this thing and build something new
i'm gonna have to
i can't build anything on shame
you're you're right but millions and
millions and millions and millions of
people do
okay
i guess just what's the practical steps
then i don't know if i've ever been
taught how to live in the
everyday yeah
so here's some practical stuff the first
thing is before you go on like another
marriage retreat or something
spectacular here's the thing those
things come with a lot of pressure
and if they're still smoldering ash that
pressure can it can just lead to
something
combustible okay and so when i'm gonna
enter into like if my wife and i gonna
go to a retreat of some sort we've got a
plan as to what we're going in to get
out of this thing
if we're going on vacation like we talk
about in our house what's this fake do
we need this just to be a reckless
wheels off weekend together do we need
just do you need to sleep and i just i'm
going to go for hikes or whatever like
we are really intentional about what the
plan is otherwise we both go in with
different plans and then we both go in
different plans we have different
fantasies about what's gonna be on the
back end of this thing we're all gonna
be all in love again no we're not that
guy just slept the whole weekend
or we're gonna have crazy sex all
weekend we're gonna reconnect and find
not really just want to go to a movie
i'm tired right and my knee hurts like
whatever the thing is
and so you have to be super intentional
way in advance and so okay here's what
it looks like number one it looks like
you being honest with the shame and
honest with the secrets
and either there's a couple of things
you haven't told him yet
not talking about gory details about
whatever we can get away or whatever i'm
not talking about that
i'm talking about
you this is a terrible idea and you knew
it while you were in it and you need to
say that out loud
or
it what you don't think it was a
terrible idea and you gave it a shot and
then you realized halfway through
you just be honest shame eats secrets
for breakfast
so there's got to be a season of honesty
and you have to give him a safe space to
be honest too
he will probably say things that are
hard to hear is that fair
totally fair okay
have you been totally honest with him
100
yeah i have okay then this will be about
creating a space for him to talk and
then here's the goal
what are your needs so i'm going to ask
you that what do you need
what makes you feel alive what made you
feel alive
feeling seen by the person seeing that i
was having a rough day without actually
saying it or
that my family went off on one of their
drunken tangents again and i could
actually express my emotion to the
person and have them be supportive like
i need to feel seen and supported okay
here's what a great gift is and this is
not in any hollywood movie okay
okay you being really clear with him
about what being seen looks like
okay and
in the moment
when you are not feeling seen you say it
not angry and not out of rage but out of
you're a teacher and it's a gift
this is a moment when
i need you just to come hug me and sim
so sorry your day was hard and say
nothing else
okay
okay the same as you gave this other
knucklehead um that benefit of the doubt
like i like this in bed or i like that
you taught him those things teach your
husband the important stuff okay
okay fair
fair and he gets to tell you what he
needs and by the way being seen is just
one because being seen is part one of i
need you to see all of me and please
still love me and for a kid with a six
on the aces score a lot of people have
had their way with you
both emotionally and otherwise
and you have a
spinning
uh
like a fusion center in your heart that
tells you what you're worth
and it is one percent of what the truth
is okay
okay am i right
yes yeah you are okay
so
you're gonna have to let him tell you
what his needs are and you can't fly off
the handle and you can't shut down
right
run away that's me there we go you go
hide there you go you can't shut down
you got to stay present with him and say
i need you to teach me will you walk
alongside me in this
and then you're going to have to in the
same conversation
preferably over a meal i like him over a
meal that's just me because i like
eating when i'm sad
and that's not a sad thing i just i just
eat my feelings and so there we go
so
you don't have to you can do it on a
hike or whatever
um and then you have to say
in one year
i want to
this to feel and look like this
in two years in five years i want this
thing to look like this this thing being
our marriage and if our marriage is not
alive it's just a reflection of what i'm
putting into it and reflection of what
he's putting into it
okay okay
so hear me say this
um
i know of no quality data
that suggests an open marriage solves
anything
i just have i haven't seen the data it
makes no sense
okay um i've seen some crappy crappy
studies and i know it's super cool to
talk about with like yeah bro we're
adults we can just be adult that's just
stupid
you know what i mean i also told myself
when i turned like was an adult that i
could eat taco bell every day and that
was a terrible choice too i'm an adult
bro i can just do whatever i want not
great right
and so here's the deal
um
you have to decide what we want this
thing to look like and you're going to
reverse engineer it you're going to be
curious with each other and be patient i
do think um
if you're both invested in this thing
you can have an extraordinary marriage
moving forward i really believe that
okay but you have to decide he's worth
it and you have to decide that you're
worth it
he can't materialize into your soul mate
he's going to become your soul mate
after 25 years of grinding things out
and if you all rebuild something
beautiful
and powerful and strong
man
then you look back and say look what we
did together and he's gonna be like
remember that time you and you're gonna
be like shut up stop we're not talking
about it
right
there yes yes totally fair okay okay all
of this starts with you getting with
your counselor that you're still seeing
and say i'm time i'm tired of carrying
these bricks of shame around we're gonna
start working on setting them down some
of that will be about writing something
that'll be about um
you know they'll have a process with you
with your therapist every therapist
works with shame and if they don't god
help you go get another therapist
okay but this is gonna be about building
something together with him and hearing
me say you are worth
a marriage that is alive
practice desire
it is a practice what do you need what
are the ons and offs so here's two
things i'm gonna send you a copy of own
your past change of future my new book
so stay on the line here and i also want
you to get a copy of
emily nagoski's book come as you are
um it's a book about sex and intimacy
for women but it's incredible for i i've
just found a really invaluable resource
um there's probably a lot of stuff in
there that you don't need to hear but
there's some incredible sections on offs
and ons and gas pedals and breaks in
this idea about sexuality and intimacy
and how to have conversations together
inside of a marriage
um and there's gonna be stuff in there
you don't like blow like move on past it
it's like all books are going to be that
way you can find stuff in my book that
you don't like too
my book's going to walk you through okay
you've got a mess you got to own it and
then now what are you going to do moving
forward and it'll give you a blueprint
for moving forward there and her book
will give you some conversations to have
with your husband and he needs to read
it too right
thank you for being honest and
[Music]
set the bricks down man
let's excavate this whole thing and
let's start anew let's build something
beautiful we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation
for exercise for talking with a mentor
for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john dolone show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we're back let's go to ann in
grand rapids what's up ann
hi thank you for taking my call dr john
thank you for calling what's happening i
well i'm hoping you can help me i listen
to your podcast
probably from the inception and um also
bought the first book and gave it to my
daughter we're going to talk about today
about the anxiety
oh you're
awesome she does
so um she has struggled in the past
she's 36 now two beautiful girls and a
great marriage and all of that but she
has struggled with
eating disorder slash exercising
disorder now
once when she was 16 and high school
cheerleader all of that and went to the
doctor we got through it the doctor
always said her best quality was her
worst quality being determined and all
of that
then
fast forward the beginning of the
marriage they went through she went
through it again right before she got
married and we thought it was nerves or
whatever but now
it's taken
it's reared its ugly head again and we
know i listen to you a lot i move your
body every day exercise every day
and she did that but to an extreme
um
so a i don't know how to walk subside
her and support her b i don't even know
what an addiction is i don't understand
it
and
how like
do i keep my walking that's what i do
for exercise but never to an extreme
because i can find anything to decide
not to do it
how do i support her
by going going through this now i will
say she has she's in counseling now
who referred her to a psychiatrist to
help with meds which she
made that appointment and went to that
she has to see her medical doctor
actually on
wednesday
so she is
she's doing what she needs to do but i
seem to always be saying the wrong thing
like did you exercise today did you eat
today
did you
you know
that sort of thing so i need some help
oh i love it
can i say i like i love your heart
like thank you i'm glad they're yes
that's awesome
um yes let me circle back to that i want
to make sure i don't forget that too um
i'm writing myself a note here um
all right so
um
there's been some data out recently that
during the pandemic
um eating disorders particularly in
women have skyrocketed off the chart
it's been
wild and there's multiple reasons why
people think and everyone's really just
kind of throwing stuff at a wall and i
think it's probably a little bit of all
of it right all this extra stress
control which you can control
um all the media messages about you know
the people especially the pandemics set
off like
i'm learning seven languages and i'm
gonna learn to do this and i'm gonna
re-roof my house all the stuff that
people said they were doing and then
most of us just sat at home eating
cheetos
and then we're like uh i guess i you
know what i mean so there's all
kinds of stuff
um one quick question how old are her
daughters
four
and seven okay barry
doesn't want them to see this very
protective of this and if i can
interject and i apologize
about the pandemic
she and the head covet and when
when they back dated to when the
psychiatrist had asked her how far back
can she go to
she realized when she had coveted
that it seemed like to trigger something
in her brain because even if we look at
photos up into that point
she always worked out but she just amped
it up and she is eating but she isn't
eating enough
to burn the calories because she'll do a
hit workout 80 minutes every morning get
her girls off to school and then go on a
four mile walk and i walk for exercise
just exercise i forget the hit part and
um
you know so i i mean i'm that's it's the
whole thing well and this is this is
hard right because our culture gives you
a gold star
for gym time
yeah and it's
when you combine that with disordered
eating or just an addiction of itself i
tend to see it as an extension of
disordered eating it's a way that it's a
way to
when i've hung out with folks who are
working through this
spent time with young people who are
working through eating disorders
there's almost a mania about every
movement can burn a calorie here in a
calorie there right it becomes this like
a well i'll just stand up and i'll just
walk i'm going to walk around while
we're talking or can we just go for a
walk instead of sitting in your office
it's this constant hey i've got three
minutes i could probably burn another
cow right here and man then you go to
the gym all the time and she's got
people in her life i guarantee you that
i fired her for her
discipline and her diligence and all
that kind of stuff right yep
so and i get so mad at them i know but
listen listen
they're just trying to love her and they
don't know
right and yeah and it's a darn fitness
watch but she finally gave that fitness
watch up to her husband last week good
and i'll tell you this i gave mine up
i put mine away did you really i did uh
i was waking up in the second i opened
my eyes i was checking it and there's
some emerging data these things are all
new that it it can lead people to be
obsessive
and most importantly it disconnects you
from how you feel
it should be a tool that teaches you oh
this is what it feels like when i
haven't slept well or this is what is i
feel like when i had two glasses of wine
and a burger last night and i woke up
this morning feeling like i got hit by a
dump truck
that's you're supposed to look at this
watch and it'll tell you right
well now the watches have become we
become slaves to the watches right and
so good for her
um
here's what she needs and you and i
could talk for a while here's what she
really needs from you she needs your mom
okay
not a
she doesn't need a checklist she doesn't
need accountability she's got a doctor
a psychiatrist and a counselor
what she needs is someone who will just
love her
i can do that i know you can um quick
note hurting yourself or putting
yourself in a precarious position does
not support her so you i would say you
have to keep walking
you need that okay okay
yeah and
people eating people exercising she's
not doing it because she's like i don't
know what i'm gonna do today oh there's
somebody exercising i think i'm gonna go
do that that's not how that works
right so you keep taking care of
yourself in the way that you need to
take care of yourself
what i would i think would be a
wonderful gift for hers to sit down and
say okay we're here again
and
you've mentioned a couple of times so i
hope tell me if i'm putting words in
your mouth you've said things over the
years that you regret or you may have
said the wrong thing here or i wish i'd
done it like this or when i think back
to when she was 16 if i had just right
you've had those thoughts right 100
percent
have you ever taken her out
and just
told her that
well we go out i try to but i always say
the wrong thing so i guess no i didn't
say that like i'll say
um
oh good you're eating yeah dad never
never said whatever yeah i know i never
say that now because it wasn't like it
was before but
it's the exercise part and then so i'll
say did you walk today did you yeah yeah
i did make these mistakes yeah yeah so
here's what i'm saying
here's what it would look like it would
look like you inviting her out
for a meal if that's not a triggering
event for her right now and no no she
loves it or y'all just go get coffee you
come together and you tell her
um
honey
i've never really opened up with you and
i'm going to today okay
and if you said
here's some things that i feel like i
haven't done well
i ask you every time i realize that
every time we get together
um
it's like a
i'm creating a shame cycle because i'm
going i'm picking you apart as though
all you are is a series of behaviors
that i'm sorry
what you need is your mom
and
i'm gonna love you and i'm gonna care
about you and i'm not gonna let you kill
yourself in front of me
right but
i love you
and you're getting the help that you
need and i need to know
and this is where you're going to give
her the greatest gift number one you've
given her vulnerability and said i made
some mistakes
okay and if you haven't done that in the
past
man no i need to do that that's a gift
for your children okay she'll she'll say
the counselor says you're setting me
back by asking me these questions and
i'm thinking i don't want you to because
i remember you saying that the bells and
the whistles and you know
these things and i listen to the bulimic
one it's nothing like that this isn't
the exercises out of control that's
right that's right that's right but
here's the thing by asking her if she
walked
is not going to keep her from walking
truly that's not
and so you've used the same tactics for
20 years and i would suggest try
something else
yeah because those tactics haven't
worked so we're going to start with
vulnerability hey i'm your mom and i've
never really told you i wish i could do
some stuff over i screwed this up and
i'm sorry
and you
might have to feel that for the first
time
yeah and if you do
let her see you feel it
okay because right now you're an app to
her you're a robot
who's going to ask her about charts and
graphs every time you all get together
and she just wants her mom she's got
professionals to deal with the charts
and graphs
that's true and so she wants her mom
and it may be before you even have a
conversation say you know what i've not
done in a long long time
i haven't just hugged you until your
guts hurt can i hug you
and i want you to take your bare hand
and put it on the back of her bare neck
and i want you to hug her for count 30.
and when she starts to pull away go can
i just keep doing this for a minute
okay
yeah i will for sure and if you don't
say it regularly i want you to tell her
i love you
the number yeah i do all the time okay
good okay good
and
i want you to give her permission to
teach you
how you can best speak to her
okay and don't say things like well i
guess i've just said the wrong things
don't do that because that puts it on
her
own it yeah
i have
said things every time you come i'm
always asking you about what's on the
scale if you were exercising what are
you doing and i'm stopping that effect
effective immediately i'm done
what i want to be is your mom
and i need you to teach me
what what are some things i could say to
you that would make you feel loved
ah okay
yes invite her into that
and then hear me say this
there will come a moment when you got to
hold boundaries okay
there's a moment when you're not just
gonna sit there and let your daughter
die
right right right and there's a moment
that might come and i'm speaking into
only because i've lived this not lived
it but i've seen it
that you are part of an intervention
team that takes her daughters away
because she's in the hospital or
whatever let's hope it doesn't get there
but that day may come right and you
gotta hold space for it
right
let's cross that bridge when we get
there
okay okay because right now you project
into the future and you're trying to
control things that you can't control
and it's best to open your hands and say
can i hug my baby girl
i will do that because you hit every
nail on the head i have said oh you know
i'm happy to take the girls whatever you
need you know what i'm whatever you need
and i'm looking so far because you know
i don't want anything bad to have you
know and that's what i'm afraid of you
know and she had opened up to my husband
and i as well that she was concerned
about that and we just said we'll walk
with you but i do i have said exactly
what you've said and i haven't done
exactly what
hey we're all figuring this out hey um
here's another thing
feel free to tell her
um once a month i'm going to call you
and ask you how you're
doing okay tell her i'm gonna call you
on this particular day because i love
you
how do you want me to have that call
with you because i am gonna check on my
daughter
okay
and she might say i would prefer you not
for a season and say cool i'll give it
two months rest and we'll revisit this
okay this isn't you just cashing out his
mom
this is you reframing mom is not being a
10 year old she's not 10 anymore have
you this morning when my son was going
to school he's 12. i said you brush your
teeth put on deodorant comb your hair
yes yes you got the chickens you fed the
dog like i went through the whole thing
she's 36.
she's 36 right
right no you're
right you're you're 100 right i just
don't and i don't understand how like
exercise something so good for you can
become an addiction listen i don't
understand you can get addicted to
anything what i would tell you is she's
not a problem to be solved she's not a
an issue to be figured out she's a
daughter to like right
yes
most of the time almost all of the time
well i'll get in trouble for saying that
i don't care i think addiction is some
sort of derivative of a connection issue
okay it's a body trying to
um
wallpaper over the alarms ringing that
say i'm out of i'm out of sync with
relationships in my life
now eating disorders is its own special
demon it kills more people it's a mess
right so
at the derivative
i'm addicted to exercise i don't even
don't even know if i'd characterize it
as as is that at this point i think it's
probably an offshoot of disordered
eating but now i'm playing psychiatric
gymnastics and am not a psychiatrist and
b it doesn't help a mom and a daughter
right right the important thing is
put put the addiction stuff in your back
pocket just put in your back pocket what
i mean okay and even say this you want
to be a gangster tell her hey i think i
might go see a counselor
and if you ever want to come with me or
you want me to go to yours with you i'd
be happy to do that
i've told her that right i have told her
that i will go any any time with her i
just needed to handle myself with the
things that you were saying that i was
saying i love it did you exercise did
you yeah no more that and you tell her
you got you got you got pros for that
that's not even my job anymore it's
awesome i would if i were you like i'm
thinking of myself i'm sitting down to
have a conversation with one of my kids
i would write this all out i'd write it
out because i'd get flustered and then
she would challenge me on one thing and
then i'd get all distracted i would
write this out and say i want to read
this to you this is after the big hug
moment i'm going to read this to you and
wait till we're all the way finished
please
and hear me say this
to have a mother
who's still not giving up on her
daughter
is the greatest gift any kid could ask
for
so on behalf of the 30 and 40 year olds
out there listening to this thank you
for being a mom that won't let your
daughter go
and most importantly thank you for being
a mom who says okay what i've been doing
isn't working i'm gonna try something
else
that's awesome she's lucky to have you
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
one five nine one in the mls consumer
access dot org equal housing lender 1749
mallory lane suite 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right let's take unimas let's go to
nova we'll go to supernova in austin
texas what's up nova
hey how's it going partying what are you
up to
uh just working it's a monday i know i'm
at work too i'm not partying at all i
just lie to myself it feels
it's raining outside it's just one of
those days so we're having a party so
what's up nova
um so
i am
in um
i'm a bit of a unicorn or so i've been
told
um
i'm in kind of a situation where i don't
really know
how to navigate the um
the relationships going forward in my
life
um so i am 39
um i
have been married a few times um the
first time i got married i
it was um
volatile and
um
you know not a good situation and so
that marriage was short-lived i you know
divorced at about
i think i was like 25 by the time i
divorced
um remarried and and it was my happily
ever after um or so i thought um we were
married about nine years and he passed
away
um drunk driving oh man
he was drunk driving or somebody hit him
he was oh man i'm so sorry
and um
um
together we were raising my son from my
previous marriage and so you know
um i was
after i lost him you know
single mom in it through grief and
um
you know that was a struggle
um for a couple of years and i
s at about the one one and a half year
mark i started feeling like my normal
self again
changed but you know the new normal
um and i opened myself back up to love
and
went out there and you know
i felt good again um and so i started
dating
um reunited with
an old friend from high school we hit it
off
um
things were going great
we got married
um
and
we were married a little over a year
and
covert happened
and
he died
come coming out the front door are you
serious
mm-hmm
is this how we uh when
um we're going on a year now god
almighty i'm so sorry
yeah
just got sick and passed away how how
long was it between when he got sick
till when he passed away
three weeks
wow he was
you know 40 no pre-existing conditions
no nothing that was alarming and
he got covered and
we thought he was just sleeping it off
you know like the first couple of days
he was just very tired and
and on day three when i went in to
check on him i noticed his lips were
turning blue
and i was like oh my goodness we're
going to the hospital and we live
you know three miles from the hospital
so i rushed him there and and
within a day he was intubated never came
home huh yeah
do you have it so across these three
marriages do you have kids involved in
this too
right so that's where that's where it
gets tricky so
um
you know his his he has two daughters
i have my son
um and
his daughters came to live with us
the january
so they've been with us a little over a
year now year and a half okay
how old are they
um uh 20 and almost 16. okay
so one's still a minor one's one's an
adult right okay
and they came to liverpool
how old's your son
he's 18. okay
and who's his dad
his dad is jesse he was my first husband
okay all right cool yeah so he still
gets visitation with his dad and
um he's 18 now so he's kind of free to
the world now right yeah okay yeah yeah
so all right so now thank you for
playing that i'm you've been through a
lot and i'm so sorry that is a lot of
trauma good grief
yeah
in a short amount of time yes yes yes
okay so years past
so are you are you back out
so i'm back out okay um you know i'm i'm
doing well considering everything like
the thing is it's
you know kind of the way that i explain
it to people unfortunately it's almost
like muscle memory like i've already i
know how to walk the walk yeah
and so
i'm good i'm working full-time i'm
holding down the fort at home i still
have my
social life and you know i'm
i'm good um you've grieved this
i have okay yeah okay yeah
i'm not in mourning yep i do still
grieve sometimes of course absolutely
but it's not that deep deep yeah that
black hole that's right that's right
okay
so you're back out there
so i'm dating what's his name
um don't tell me his name
okay david
okay yeah
um he's great
um
he's very understanding of the situation
he knows you know yeah he knows what
he's getting into
hey listen he has no idea what he's
getting into not even close
but i like that he believes that he does
that's cool good for him yeah
yeah
the the hard part for me is you know
first and foremost i'm thinking about
the kids you know and
and they
we talk a lot and you know i
i don't put them in situations where i
feel like they're not ready you know we
are all
kind of walking through this and
sometimes it feels like we're walking
through mud but we're you know we make
it through and and we're doing okay
and they you know they've met him they
like him we're all adjusting well okay
where it gets tricky is
um
because they are my late husband's kids
and they live with me i'm getting
custody
okay
um
they you know still have a relationship
with his family and they still want a
relationship with his family and
and i do too to some extent but things
are a little bit different now right
and you know take for example this past
easter
there was a big family
easter barbecue
and
they were like oh we're going right like
the whole family they want to go
and
you know
i i feel
like i want to be there i want to be
part of the family that they so
desperately want because their family
has slowly started
you know with their dad passing and then
grandpa passed you know a couple months
later like
they want that family
um so let me just different so
distill this down into a question for me
how do i
blend
my
new
relationship going forward because we're
we're at the point where
we don't
we're at the point where we're blending
lives we want we're wanting to do things
together as a family okay
so um
here's my here's like let me just i'll
hop in let me here's my thoughts on it
if you're adopting
these two
if you are taking guardianship with them
especially the minor
you are taking guardianship you are you
are opting into their entire family the
same as you did when you married him
okay
i think they're right
especially when they're a minor i think
you go to the family events
and if you're um
they need that level of
security you've been through this before
they have not
you're an adult and it's brutal and you
you know the black hole
they are kids and that black hole will
be in
they will be in that black hole for
years
and so having strings and connections to
let me say it this way you can't adopt
these two kids and then just have them
cut off their families and say we're
starting something new that can't be oh
right that can't work yeah so i think i
think it's right and fair to
let your new
boyfriend who might become your fiance
who might become your new husband
someday
say this is part of what we do is we go
visit
and i've got people in my life that are
friends who married somebody whose
spouse passed away and they go visit and
it's kind of weird
and that's just part of what happens
when you sign up for a blended family
it's just different it's a challenge
every blended family situation is
different
the cornerstone is a we got to take care
of these kids first they got to feel
safe and connected both to their lineage
and their legacy and to what we're doing
that's new
right that's number one and number two
is we're kind of all making this up as
we go so we have to over over over
communicate
when your new boyfriend says hey i feel
weird there he needs to have permission
and space to say it and you don't fly
off the handle at him and when you say i
don't really feel like going you get to
be able to say that to him and him be
able to say yeah but it's probably the
right thing
and it's that weird balance of that 16
year old in that especially the 20 year
old that 16 year old doesn't get to hurt
your feelings and at the same time she's
hurting so bad god almighty so bad so
bad right and so let's go see
grandmother and granddad let's just make
that a part of what we're going to do
every year
that makes sense
yeah
i think
the tendency to want to clear the deck
and move on from this hurt is going to
be there's going to be a really
attractive pull to that for you
is that fair
for for me not the kids like i i never
want them just like i
i'm completely
great with them going in to see their
family like i don't want to pull them
from that but i do find myself
you know kind of
stepping back because they his family
knows i'm dating and i don't want
anybody to feel disrespected i don't
want them to feel like oh i don't think
yeah i don't think they will and if they
do call them
say hey i'm dating somebody new and
we're all coming would it be okay if i
brought him
i think you for the next four years next
two or three years i think you i think
you go
to these type of family events or
whatever
at graduation i think you invite her
grandparents and her aunts and uncles
and cousins and you have them over to
your house even if you're married by
then
right everybody nobody is under the
illusion that you know what i mean like
it's it's the secrets that are going to
start to cause fissures and cracks in
the family
and so we're just going to keep secrets
and if somebody says hey we really would
prefer you not to bring your new
boyfriend over to the house it's just
it's just too soon for us say great cool
i'm just gonna be respectful because
this isn't about them it's not about
getting in a fight and like well this is
me no it's about those kids
right and then when they turn 18 and the
other one's 22 now we're having a whole
different conversation you don't have to
go to all those things anymore because
they're adults and they can go to where
they want to right
i think it's not overthinking it and
also not
i mean you're doing a noble thing by
taking these kids
a truly noble thing
but by doing that
you're you're entrenching yourself in
this family for a season or really
forever but especially for us
right right right um
and i think that's good and i think it's
really hard
i think both of those can be the true at
the same time
does that does that make your heart hurt
to think about that
it
it makes me nervous
why
i
i just
um
i don't know like death brings out the
ugly in people and i'm i'm nervous that
because
i'm i would be with somebody new like if
you know he came with us to the
functions
that they would be
not
receptive to that and so what you're
doing right now is you're projecting
into the future something that hasn't
happened yet
and you are choosing to be anxious and
possibly make life altering family
decisions and choices over something
that hasn't happened yet and you don't
really have a clear answer on
and the only way you can get clear
answers in this there's two ways one you
can just show up and spring on them and
see what happens which is a terrible
idea or you can call ahead
you can send an email out to the family
you can let everybody know hey i'm
adopting these kids i'm going to be all
in on this family and i am dating again
and if i bring somebody know that it's
not disrespect it's it's me wanting
y'all to know what's going on in my life
and y'all and me to know what's going on
y'all's life if anyone has any concerns
please reach out and let me know
and what we're doing here is we're not
trying to win this is about hospitality
this is about kindness and it's about
those kids but i'm not going to give any
real estate in my heart and mind for
imagining things that might or might go
sideways or someone might get mad they
may think i'm moving on too quick that
sounds like you might be wondering if
you're moving on too quick not them but
they might be and they may say you he's
not welcome here you're not welcome here
okay
they're hurting
and if it brings out the ugly in them
that's fine i'm not going to let them
bring out the ugly envy
i'm just not i'm not going to give them
that power over my life
i'm just not
and you've been through a lot and so as
you walk through this nova give yourself
some grace okay give yourself some grace
be open with those kids be open with
your new boyfriend
make sure he's nice
make sure he's nice
and
man
communicate communicate communicate
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life
as you read through each section of this
book i will show you how to look and own
the roads from your past and head to the
new roads of a well life moving forward
go to johndaloni.com to get your copy
today that's own your past change your
future at johndaloni.com
we are back
and it's story time here on the dr john
oloney show
i tried to say that in my least creepy
voice did i get it no it's kind of
creepy it's good it's good
all right so
today we're going to
discuss
a classic and i know this is going to
get me in trouble with the moms across
the world
it's called love you forever by robert
munsch
munch is that he say it
munchkuch
illustrated by sheila mcgraw
and normally you would think i love this
book it's got a child playing in a
toilet i think that's hilarious but i'm
gonna read it here we go
not all of it mind you it's a thousand
pages oh here's my pipe
i don't even know whose pipe this is
is that yours sorry about that man
i'm fairly certain i'm covered free all
right
a mother held her new baby
and very slowly rocked him back and
forth back and forth back and forth and
while she held him she's saying i lo
i'll love you forever i'll like you for
always as long as i'm living my baby
you'll be
the baby grew and he grew and he grew
and he grew he grew all right we get it
he grew until he was two years old and
he ran all around the house he pulled
all the books off the shelves he pulled
all the food out of the refrigerator and
he took his mother's watch and flushed
it down the toilet
sometimes his mother would say this kid
is driving me crazy well that's rude
but at night when the two-year-old was
quiet
she opened the door to his room kind of
creepily stalked a little bit like a
murderer crawled across the floor looked
up over the side of his bed
as if he was really asleep and if he was
really asleep she picked him up and
rocked him back and forth back and forth
back and forth
while she rocked him she's saying i'll
love you forever i'll like you for
always as long as i'm living my baby
you'll be
and if you've ever read a book to a kid
at night
when you've got stuff to do
you this is the part when you realize oh
my gosh this is going to take like 30
minutes because this book goes on
forever so i'm just going to fast
forward the kid uh is in middle school
she's still picking him up hugging him
back and forth back and forth back and
forth
um he's still trashing the place only
now he's got booze and microphones and
pizza and kids
but back and forth back and forth she
still crawls around on the floor
sneaking up on his bed
ah my mom ever go uh
three three and then
this is when the book
in my opinion gets off the rails
that teenager grew and he grew and he
grew until he became a grown-up man
he left home and got a house across town
but sometimes on dark nights
the mother got into her car and she
drove across town
has anyone ever seen the shining
and if all the lights out
in the sun's house of all the lights in
her son's house were out she opened his
bedroom window crawled across the floor
and looked up over the side of his bed
this is when you call 9-1-1 folks if
there's a woman crawling into your
window call 9-1-1
and if you think i think that's my
elderly mother especially call 9-1-1 for
you because you'll probably see
oh god okay so
then she crawls she gets a ladder on top
of her car by the way so she's not
breaking entering into her grown man
son's house
through the window and this cat still
sleeping in a single bed that's a whole
other conversation
it yeah we needed that yeah
okay so
um
if all the lights in her son's house
were out she opened his bedroom window
crawled across the floor and looked up
over the side of his bed
if that great big man was really asleep
which suggests that there was times that
she crawled across the floor and he was
awake and she was like sorry son see you
later and she just crawled back out the
window but alas if he was truly asleep
maybe he'd had four or five ambien if
that great big man was really asleep and
she rocked him back and forth and back
and forth and back and forth and while
she rocks she's saying
i'll love you forever
like a stalker
or murderer perhaps
i'll love you for always as long as i'm
living my baby you'll be
oh
boy
then he comes around
and hugs his mom it's a beautiful ending
so i think it's just important to call
out the serial killer part in the middle
of this beautiful story she loved your
little boy
and then um he hugged her
his mom
it's awesome it's beautiful
when the son came home that night he
stood for a long time at the top of the
stairs
oh no
this is how generational trauma gets
transmitted kids now he picks up his
daughter
and starts the whole creepy thing over
again
oh no
i'm gonna re i'm gonna reimagine the
ending then he picked up his daughter
out of her crib
i looked at her and said i love you baby
and i always will
but i'm not just gonna sneak in and
break into your house and you're an
adult woman and climb through your
bedroom window and crawl across your
floor
and wait till you're passed out of sleep
and then hug you
a lot
it's not going to do that
i'm going to raise you
to be able to verbalize your needs
and to let you know that i love you at
all times
that's i love you forever by uh bob
munch
way to go bob
well that's the end of that show as i
slowly take off the sweater and if
you're listening to this podcast yes
indeed you should probably watch this on
youtube
and uh
don't forget to give us five star
reviews
anywhere you consume the uh this podcast
don't forget to subscribe and tell your
friends
about the incredible groundbreaking work
we're doing here on the dr john dolone
show the greatest mental health podcast
ever
oh as we wrap up today's show song by
the lumineers is called ophelia it's a
little bit on the nose but it goes like
this ah when i was younger
i should have known better i can't feel
no remorse and you don't feel nothing
back got a new girlfriend he feels like
he's on top and i don't feel no remorse
and you can't see past my blinders
ophelia you've been on my mind girl
since the flood ophelia heaven help a
fool who falls in love
honey i love you and that's all she
wrote
ophelia that's all she wrote
we're staying off the rails we'll see
you soon
coming up on the next episode we're both
struggling with a little bit of
gender disappointment we we both were
really hoping for a little girl and
while we are excited we are having
another little boy and there's going to
be pee everywhere
there is everywhere you know fantastic
that's right so we found out a few weeks
ago that a extended relative has been
sexually molesting our six-year-old
daughter and then we
involved the authorities at that point
there has been some negative feedback
from other family members on that yeah
we'll screw them they don't get a vote